well in the first part of our story
earlier we looked into gated communities
and assess their actual safety and part
two
what you can do right now to keep you
your family and your neighborhood
safer wherever you live and what crucial
mistakes
need to be avoided
in part one of our story on gated
communities and home safety we found
nationally fewer residential burglaries
in gated communities
and less vandalism speeding and
opportunistic crime
other studies found gated in ungated
neighborhoods with nearly identical
rates of burglaries in car theft
and one definite downside of gated
communities is slower emergency response
times
i think it's critical that you get to
know your neighbors and the experts
agree
two of our local leaders with henderson
pd and metro police
highlighted the importance of
consistently connecting with neighbors
if you know your neighbors you can refer
officers to your neighbors and
your neighbors are really going to be
wanting to help and
assist us in that investigation it's
amazing how when i'm outside and i talk
with my neighbors and i see cars driving
by
you know i often will see somebody that
i didn't know lived in the neighborhood
because i'm outside now i get to
recognize that they're there or we'll
see something that just doesn't look
right we're like wow i've never seen
that car before
why is that person driving like that
homeowners in both gated and ungated
communities can fall victim
simply because of lacks behavior there
are basic
safety steps you can take right now just
lock the door to your house
you lock your car at night just lock
your car don't give that criminal the
opportunity to
take advantage of it and please get
specific check the screws on the front
door
you want at least two to three inch
screws in that main door of defense
i took steps you know to lock my gates
and
you know we keep our house locked i put
a security door on my front door
one thing experts say stop doing the
hey we're off to hawaii for two weeks
post my encouragement on social media
post is just wait until after you come
back from your vacation
and instead of telling instagram you're
out of town tell a trusted neighbor
about
travel deliveries or work being done on
your home
if you have all those friends in your
neighborhood allow let them know that if
you're going to have
anything being delivered to your house
if you're expecting someone to come over
and check
let them know police also advise get any
valuables and the garage clicker out of
the car
they recommend home defense measures and
security cameras
as well as registering those cameras
through a program like capture
which can assist police in catching a
criminal i don't think there's a
difference in
gated or outdated communities whichever
community you live in
it seems much of the safety of our
family our home
ultimately falls on the shoulders of our
neighbors
and us my experiences are as an officer
for 20 years now
is that crime can happen anywhere
now you can find both part one and part
two to our story on gated and ungated
communities and home
safety on our website over at eight
newsnow dot com